s'armer contre le virus
être solidaire tout en apprenant voilà
le quotidien de teresa 22 ans étudiant
en troisième année de médecine est
désormais employées à temps partiel dans
le service interne de cet hôpital de
prague
cette jeune fille tchèque peut enchaîner
jusqu'à 10 permanence de 12 heures par
mois chacune comprenant six heures en
soins intensifs et 6h d'autres tâches
une expérience formidable pour elle cela
dépend si les infirmières et les autres
membres du personnel ont besoin d' aide
si les infirmières n'ont pas besoin de
moi
les médecins me laisse souvent effectué
différentes interventions médicales que
je ne ferais pas en tant qu'étudiante
teresa n'est pas la seule étudiante à
prêter main forte
ils sont des centaines à s'être porté
bénévole pour aider les hôpitaux tchèque
débordant de malades ducobu 19 aux
prises avec l'un des taux d'infection
parmi les plus élevés au monde
le ministère tchèque de la santé
chiffrent à plus de 800000 les cas
confirmés du kobe 19 depuis le début de
l'épidémie dont près de 13000 d'essai
pour relever le défi
le gouvernement a fait appel aux
étudiants ainsi qu'aux militaires les
étudiants en médecine nous aident à
positionner les patients il participe à
la toilette matinale envoie des analyses
au laboratoire ou désinfecte les
chambres ils font beaucoup de travail et
nous leur en sommes sincèrement
reconnaissant une expérience inestimable
pour ces étudiants et une aide
essentielle pour des hôpitaux de chèques
aux limites de leurs capacités d'accueil
depuis l'automne dernier
ce pays fort de 10,7 millions
d'habitants empile les morts la
république tchèque a enregistré le taux
de mortalité quotidien par habitant le
plus élevé d'europe pendant plusieurs
semaines en octobre et en novembre